ah ouais et regardé par an on à
guillaume delphine
colard garder la tête basse et ben on
les connaît
on dirait
cichocki la poupe est magnifique
c'est vrai qu'on fait sans rigoler c'est
ce qui c'est la poupée le mali est riche
dans les cieux à regarder on à nicolas
pernikoff et kelly
[Applaudissements]
m
nicolas pernikoff et kelly sera t-elle
ma mère la petite à la mi-temps des
régals à 65
[Rires]
épinacois y ait eu peur de nous à la
halle à tout prix de
prendre alors alors mettez moi bassamois
pas d'héritier gardien benjamin bayart
il
[Applaudissements]
a pris les yeux de son père
mon dieu quelle est une gamme
eseries attention enfants venus à venir
mais il s'agit là
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
asus est extraordinaire
tu imagines tu ici c'est vraiment comme
ça franchement c'est incroyable
on voit déjà le lot follenfant il doit
dire des phases attendu
dubitatif et enfin qu à petit on a fait
l'enfant de mathieu et moi
[Applaudissements]
les banques s'est baladé wald badiane et
walt tue et le début que le porno trop
fort il vous plait merci n'est pas temps
de le faire
satan qui n'est celui qu'il est très
réussi
et qui le porte je ne sais pas moi c'est
paddle je peux pas
non mais vraiment mais vraiment aimé
j'aimerais revoir le mettez moi parfois
mais témoin l'enfant des âges il parfois
[Rires]